301 area code caller from 301 I hope you
can hear me what's your name
where are you calling hi yes hello hi
I'm calling from Maryland okay what's on
your mind and I wanted to I wanted to
ask if you think Al Franken would be a
good candidate for the 2020 election I
think that it is too early to talk about
2020 and no I don't think he would be I
mean III think that um I don't think so
I think that he I like Al Franken a lot
I think that he is someone who has
actually been one of the stronger
progressive voices in the Senate up
there with some of the more progressive
senators but I think that political
viability it for Al Franken is a tough
thing but if Trump won who am I to say
Pat that Al Franken couldn't win right
do you oppose Al Franken because of his
former celebrity not us being in SNL no
I I mean listen under on the politics of
it I think Al Franken is a great
candidate do I think that he's the best
person to be put forward by the
Democratic Party in 2020 I don't think
so maybe I could be swayed but I think
we've got to focus on 2018 right now
anyway okay yeah thank you all right
thank you appreciate it interesting
noises on that call yeah I don't know
what that that was a very very odd noise
I'm just thinking now about what the
debates would be like between Donald
Trump and Al Franken yeah for
entertainment value alone yeah I think
those would rank very high they would
they would